[Music]
and welcome to Hannity busy Monday night
the Border show down in Texas that is
heating up it is now a constitutional
crisis and a national security crisis
and Governor Greg Abbott he's not
backing down he will join us with the
very latest plus the possible Senate
border deal would be a disaster for the
country we're going to tell you why
every Republican senator should be
strongly opposed to it but first
American soldiers abroad are under
attack three Brave members of the US
Army they were killed and we had what
over 40 more injured in a drone attack
on a base in Jordan yesterday one
official is now saying that the Drone
evaded us defenses because it was
mistaken for an American drone well that
begs the question what's going on with
our military we know our defense
secretary spent days in the ICU the
commander-in-chief had no knowledge of
it at all now there were three soldiers
dead because of a a drone proxy from an
Iranian proxy was mistaken for a us one
now since October the 17th there have
been at least 165 attacks carried out on
our US forces you see the locations on
your screen how many more times do
American troops need to be targeted and
attacked before we have a president that
will take action and defend them after
all the previous attacks and no response
from President Joe this now became
inevitable
just like no consequences ever for
Russia or China or Iran all these groups
causing chaos and destruction in the
Middle East you have Hamas esbah uh the
the houti rebels they're all funded and
backed by Iran the number one state
sponsor of Terror former president Trump
called out Biden for his weakness on
Truth social saying quote this Brazen
attack on the United States is yet
another horrific and tragic consequence
of Joe Biden's weakness and surrender
and speaking in South Carolina yesterday
Biden had an opportunity to send a
strong message to his friends his Pals
the mullers and Iran uh in the wake of
these deadli attacks but instead he
offered nothing but this tepid response
take a listen one last thing I I want to
point out that we had a tough day last
night in the Middle East we lost three
brave souls and attack
B yes
ask
Jesus and we shall
respond and we shall
respond this is pretty much power for
the course with this Administration who
instead of using forceful deterrence
just had a simple message for Iran all
along their message whenever asked well
what about Iran don't don't don't watch
what is your message to Hezbollah and
its backer Iran
don't don't don't don't and what's the
message to Iran
don't as President Biden said just don't
exactly one word pretty straightforward
it was very important to send a very
clear message to anyone who might seek
to take advantage of the conflict in
Gaza to threaten our Personnel uh here
or anywhere else in the region don't do
it I've already delivered the message to
r they know know not to do
anything oh now they know not to do
anything don't becomes do and nothing
happens big shock the strategy didn't
work why would Iran the world's largest
state sponsor terrorism stop there are
no consequences for all their actions
Joe Biden's weakness is the reason that
the country of Iran and China and the
country of Russia are so embolden it is
the reason we woke up yesterday to three
dead soldiers and dozens others injured
Joe Biden is the appeaser in Chief once
again Joe Biden if he didn't respond the
other what 175 times uh what would the
Iranians expect nothing that's why he
has blood on his hands he has caused
this this Administration has reportedly
turned a blind eye to Iran getting rich
with their surging oil sales even as
they remain under Western sanctions
that's basically Joe allowing them you
know to bring billions of dollars into
their Co coffers again to sponsor more
terror Biden gave Iran what $6 billion
as Ransom payment and a prisoner swap
then the Biden Administration renewed a
sanctions waiver giving Iran access to
another1 billion in this case case from
Iraq in exchange for electricity sales
Biden is only enabling and appeasing
Iran and their ability to fund Terror
groups and the world better pay
attention because that same country Iran
is desperately trying to acquire nuclear
weapons and by the way they have now
aligned themselves with both Russia and
and China would you be shocked if Russia
and China would help them with their
nuclear program because I would not they
are now enriching uranium almost to the
point of being weapons grade that's at
least according to the latest assessment
I don't know if anybody really knows but
that is what appeasement does as Senator
Tom Cotton said in a statement yesterday
Joe Biden and Bolden Iran for years by
tolerating attacks on our troops bribing
the AAS with billions of dollars and
appeasing them to no end he left our
troops as sitting ducks and now three
Americans are dead and doz dozens now
others are wounded and sadly I've been
predicting this would happen for months
so that's what Tom Cotton said so we and
then to make matters worse according to
NBC News the administration is
discussing the idea of slowing some
Weaponry to Israel what to pressure them
and to scaling back their military
operations in Gaza after the worst
terrorist attack in their history
instead of saying we support your war
against Terror that's all you have to do
Joe what is happening in the Middle East
is devastating and sadly all of it
preventable uh were it not for Joe's
fail and very weak leadership hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else